ils sont six 6 lycéens guyancourt toi et
présente je marche dans la nuit par un
chemin mauvais d'ahmed madani ils
appartiennent à l'atelier théâtre du
lycée de villeroy
quand j'ai appris qu'on allait avoir la
chance que de vrais comédiens pourrait
nous apprendra à jouer bas je me suis
dit pourquoi pas tenter ma chance
son ensemble est une bonne expérience au
final basse en est une et quand j'ai
découvert ça basma franchement plus la
pièce parle de la mémoire collective et
personnelle de cette transmission entre
les générations mais aussi de la guerre
d'algérie deux thématiques en lien avec
le programme de terminale
c'est un enjeu essentiel sur le plan
pédagogique mais aussi sur le plan
citoyens je pense que questionner notre
transmission de la mémoire des mémoires
puisque pour chaque événement historique
différentes mémoires sont en jeu parfois
même en concurrence est absolument
essentiel est la pièce permet de
l'aborder de manière vivante
est ce que ne permettrait pas à une
analyse purement historique ou
littéraire un travail de plusieurs mois
en parallèle de leurs cours un
partenariat avec la ferme de bel ébat et
la campagne et les yvelinoises in canada
nous ça nous apporte beaucoup c'est à
dire que au fur et à mesure on fait
baisser un peu par obligation mais je
vous parle d'il ya 15 20 ans quand nous
on avait commencé à développer
effectivement la compagnie les ateliers
il se trouve qu'on se rend compte que
c'est c'est une part énorme de
transmission quand on monte des pièces
on cherche à toucher un public à lui
transmettre des textes des choses comme
ça qui ne gâte peut-être ya longtemps
via moins de temps la pensée d'autres
personnes
prochaine étape pour ces lycéens des
représentations dans d'autres
établissements des yvelines et du var